we actually met yes and Mr Daniel was in
the room with me and I remember yeah yes
did your mom pass
yeah
oh my God she says it still feels like
yesterday that I died
oh my God she says his faith needs to be
restored again
do you understand that
but your your dad I don't know did you
have like a a kind of a separation with
your dad or was there a little uh
because your your mom your dad showed me
there was like a lot of ups and downs
with our relationship
and he says in through and your father
just sets me through your gift I was
able to let my son know how much I do
love him and how proud I always have
been of him and I am sorry that I was
not able to show him the love that he
deserved for me and now I see your mom
is like hitting him
hahaha